a bird's eye view of the hiran region in
central Somalia shows the extent of the
damage
after days of heavy rain the town of
beledwan is submerged and countless
homes Swept Away the storms triggered
flooding and caused the chabelle river
to burst in Spanx forcing people to Wade
through Rising water levels
it was very difficult for me to walk
this morning because of the amount of
water
he used to be able to walk through it
before but as you can see the level has
reached my waistline and this situation
is getting worse businesses
is disrupted people say these are some
of the worst floods they've seen
these floods are different to others in
the past this flood is larger than any
flooding in recent memory that has ever
occurred in this region
but for many like fortune and her family
it's not the first time they've had to
move
whenever the river bursts its banks we
flee it's the fifth time I've had to
flee and come here as a displaced person
the United Nations is warning the
flooding could increase the risk of
waterborne diseases and the government
has yet to assess the full impact of the
disaster
it is a Calamity it was an unexpected
disaster however we are doing all that
we can to protect those who are affected
extreme weather pattern are worsening
already difficult conditions for somalis
the torrential rain follows prolonged
drought which has left millions of
people dependent on food Aid the UN says
the space families need food and shelter
and fast rahila Muhammad Al Jazeera